le voici à nouveau dans les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques lyonnais les médicaments
après la longue étude des chercheurs
sorte en grosse quantité
les différentes machines tout au long de
cette fabrication depuis les matières
premières jusqu'au produit fini prêt à
être administré aux malades exerce le
contrôle ou plutôt les contrôles il
s'agit avec ces comprimés ou ces
ampoules de soigner les gens et même
souvent de leur sauver la vie
aucune erreur n'est permise dans leurs
laboratoires les spécialistes chargés du
contrôle et ils sont très nombreux dans
sa cuisine ne quitte jamais les yeux le
médicament mais voyons de plus près dans
la pratique comment se fait le comprend
il est exercé par le prélèvement des
échantillons au magasin et par des
analyses à tous les stades de la
fabrication de manière à ce que rien ne
puisse échapper ou au contrôle de
laboratoire en fait fonctionne comme un
poste de douane
louis dans toutes les opérations le
laboratoire établi une fiche de contrôle
qui suit le médicament soit au cours de
la fabrication soit au cours de son
emballage
par conséquent le produit une peu sorti
qu'avec le visa du laboratoire dans un
autre laboratoire
on fabrique du soluté injectable ou
sérum physiologique qui est en fait que
de l'eau salée et bien pour un produit
aussi simple le nombre des différents
contrôles est impressionnant on peut en
compter 26 sur les produits de matières
premières c'est à dire
simplement l'eau distillée et puis le
corps sodium comme vous le savez le sel
de cuisine donc 26 contrôle avant de
préparer ensuite commence des contrôles
en cours de fabrication qui sont aussi
nombreux et de contrôler le produit
terminé
des tests très long on arrive fabrique
un produit en 45 minutes
c'est à dire sous soluté dont vous
parlez celui de tes peurs de sodium mais
il faut en fait plus de huit jours
8 10 jours si tout marche bien pour
arriver à sortie en produits qu'ils
contrôlaient qui donc sera destiné
entrée sur la peau d'un malade
vous avez sans doute peu remarquée sur
chaque boîte de médicament sur chaque
étiquette de plaques ont un numéro
ces quelques chiffres représentent la
somme de travail du laboratoire de cons
grâce à eux on peut retrouver très
rapidement l'histoire du médicament
toutes les analyses qu'il a subie avant
d'être envoyée chez votre pharmacien
c'est en quelque sorte la garantie de la
qualité du produit
nous avons vu que l'industrie
pharmaceutique nécessité l'emploi d'un
personnel nombreux et surtout très
qualifiés l'emploi aussi de machines
complexes et coûteux mais il ne faut pas
oublier d'autres agents très important
sans lesquels beaucoup de médicaments ne
saurait être fabrique
il s'agit bien sûr des animaux de toutes
sortes d'animaux dont les services sont
essentiels
la fabrication du vaccin contre la polio
mais rip suppose l'utilisation de
nombreux singes environ 55 par semaine
permettent la fabrication et le contrôle
du vaccin qui est utilisé environ donc
pour un pour cent de la population
enfantine française
d'autre part nous citerons et cela a une
valeur historique le cas du sérum
antitétanique qui est fabriqué sur
cheveux à marcy l'étoile
si nous conservons une cavalerie de 420
chevaux qui malgré la vaccination et
malgré l'utilisation des antibiotiques
permet quand même là sérum isation de
nombreux sujets accidenté un troisième
exemple plus général celui là concerne
les animaux de laboratoire les petits
animaux de laboratoire dont vous voyez
un exemplaire ici un cobaye à marcy
l'étoile nous avons un élevage doha le
sourire de l'âme stères de cobaye est de
lapin qui permettent d'une part la
fabrication de certains produits comme
des réactifs de laboratoire pour la
sérologie le cobaye notamment
d'autre part qui permettent le contrôle
et c'est sur ce point que j'insiste le
contrôle des médicaments
il n'y a évidemment aucune fabrication
possible de médicaments surtout de
médicaments d'origine biologique sans
animaux de laboratoire le cycle est
presque terminée le médicament peut
partir chez votre pharmacien
mais là encore il reste surveillé car
dans son magasin le pharmacien est aussi
un spécialiste qualifié seul habilité à
dispenser les médicaments et c'est en
grande partie grâce à cet effort
constant
en un siècle seulement la durée de la
vie humaine a augmenté de 30 ans